now I want to talk about dementia care a
subject that isn't just close to my
heart it breaks my heart
how can we call ourselves a
compassionate nation when this
government is forcing sick frightened
vulnerable people to sell their homes
and spend their life savings on care
that should be free but isn't if
dementia sufferers had cancer treatment
would be free so why isn't it for a
condition which shatters lives loved
ones and entire families we either have
a free health care system or we don't
you cannot have one group getting
something for free and the other being
bankrupted and punished because they're
being pruned three weeks ago the British
Medical Association wanted to fling open
the doors of the NHS to foreigners from
all over the world so why are pensioners
here who unlike those health tourists
have paid into the system getting
screwed by a government that
increasingly neglects and persecute the
elderly Theresa mate promised to fix
this hideous injustice two years ago but
did nothing Boris has promised he will
and he must because doing nothing isn't
just cruel and uncaring it's immoral
[Music]
well in principle you've got to be right
now but let's label it we want to know
how much that's gonna cost us as a
society because so far we've today we've
spent a lot more money on the Royal Navy
which you supported now you're gonna
spend a lot more money on on care I mean
my mother died with dementia and it was
a horrible period of all our lives and
was terrible five years she spent in her
home and I've still I used to talk to
people around the home and said how many
people here are paying because we were
paying and they were saying it's about
50/50 but I mean full of people I mean
it is incredibly difficult but I don't
but but but there is a cost all this
time yeah I know and therefore if we
want to say okay well we'll increase
taxation in this country to pay for this
and this and this I'm all in favor I
mean I know you you'll immediately try
to say can all be paid for by a foreign
agent things pretty card we're too much
thing to me but your mind if that if if
that's what a health serve
is is three at the point of delivery
whatever your problem then there has to
be right but it does cost but I yeah and
it but I think we have a cultural
problem with our attitude to the elderly
currently I fits what I said in the
intro you know we are neglecting them we
are persecuting the most vulnerable
section of our society and and in making
them sell their homes you're literally
taking homes away from people who are
literally losing their minds and the one
thing about dementia is and you will
know this is that the the last things
people forget are things that happened a
long time ago homes are reminiscent of
all that to make someone sell that to
pay for care and the principle the
bottom line is you might have a free
healthcare system or you don't well you
can't make some pay yes as someone who
did sided we did so my mother's hope to
help fund fund her care and I don't see
it personally but anything wrong with
that
you wouldn't even you know to be fair we
know you're quite a wealthy guy even if
you hadn't had to sell her home you
would have been your mom would have been
okay but there's not who only have that
unlikely I mean what is interesting
about about how you pay for it
Damien green produced the paper for the
Center for Policy Studies and he they
came up with a series of options of how
you could pay for it they they include
you'd asked over 50s to pay more
national insurance contributions the
impacts the winter fuel allowance
homeowners make voluntary contributions
through downsizing or releasing equity
wealthy pensioners pair one off charge
of thirty thousand when they turn 65
the principle is wrong because if you're
giving one section of society care for
this free you can't then charge you live
occur because they're being prudent
enough to buy a house or save a bit of
money yeah but they've ended up with a
often they've ended up with a house
people have ended up with houses
particularly in the South that are worth
a lot of money they didn't paint like I
think I mean first of all we do need the
context that social care has been really
massively cut cut by a third nothing
since 2010 that's part of the austerity
cuts which I think were ideological and
unnecessary I agree with you Carol I
think you know people at the end of
their lives
you know of you know some of the most
vulnerable in our society and we need to
take better care of them and I think
social care it does work but if you if
you've had to deal with it it's very
very complicated even though it is good
but to get it to kick in also needs
quite a bit of work and I think this is
your for me you're making a case for
having a national social care service I
don't think it should be means-tested I
think we should all contribute it should
be free at the point of views I also
think should probably be centralized
because having it work on a sort of the
local basis makes it potentially a bit
of a national lottery which I don't
think is fair either so I would say
centralize it and also if we're going to
raise national insurance for it that
should happen for everyone and not just
the other 15 I'm wonderful ways and I
think there's a government proposal that
Hancock was looking at prior to a new
primary so whether it will he stayed
impose his Health and Social Care
socially all we see but we will all if
you make a certain amount of money make
a monthly pay much as we are encouraged
to do to a pension so let's for the
purpose of debate called it the Social
Care Fund and each month each so as well
as our insurance system it's an
insurance system and I believe it's
modeled on something but don't quote me
I think in Germany but is it that you're
okay well and it seems to work
moderately well that would seem just as
we pay into and national sean's and I we
pay why can't we have a social poor fund
you know I think we should but I think
it should be something that should be
put to the people in a general election
as part of a manifesto program I think
it's a very good idea I think just a few
key statistics a third of people have to
sell their homes to pay for their care
the cost of social curve to the state is
15 billion over two years fees in
private care homes have doubled over the
past ten years and a million people by
2025 are going to be suffering from
dementia and Alzheimer's yeah another is
a crisis wasn't the next we got escaped
with you know during the last election
it was the thing that killed trees
amazed if it was any other condition
this is the most telling whether it was
cancer whatever else heart disease we
would treat these folk it is quite
which means I must just say what we have
from the government so the Department of
Health and Social Care says everyone
affected by dementia deserves the best
possible care and support we expect
councils to offer a meaningful choice of
suitable high-quality services that meet
people's needs we have given local
authorities access of up to 3.9 billion
pounds more dedicated funding for adult
social care this year and we will set
out our plans to reform the social care
system at the earliest opportunity to
ensure it is sustainable for the future
look at the human side of what we're
talking about let's look Utah she desai
her husband has dimension that's just
let's just see what she has to say about
life for her in him his life counts and
it's not passenger you know he's still
my co-pilot in my in my plane with this
condition but I think for CH initely
people don't always see it like that so
it makes me very challenging because one
thing I want to really kind of hone in
on his before my husband had this
condition he was a father a husband a
worker a friend and when you get FTD all
the bubbles are you having your life
stop bursting that I mean that makes
people heat and and that's what we're
talking about and I think what I would I
try to say before is there was a
cultural problem now in this country
with other people it's we treat them
like they don't matter we treat the
elderly like they're a new slow your
should we have to stop at we assuming we
treat okay it's not true
so she I'm young you're right it's a
real problem you talk to anyone in local
government and they'll tell you they're
running out of the Treasury weren't they
you just kept cutting home eight hundred
ninety five people a day I'll turn the
way for state care elderly people and
and most of them have dementia that is
shocking in a country that fancies
itself as a compassionate then we have
to accept it's gonna cost and we shall
pray that yes we will agree that we
should increase taxes notice because you
look at how money is currently spent and
I've just saved you sixty billion pounds
by stopping a railway line alright or
the 14 billion pound in aid that's a
capital cost that's not that's a living
let me just stop at the point where we
all think we need to all pay a bit more
for this because we have an agreement
for a change